bonjour les enfants
à regarder un petit peu ce qu'il ya dans
ma sacoche un énorme show dont on m'a
fait cadeau la demoiselle des postes
moselle cunego oui j'ai invité ce soir
judy françois mademoiselle fut-elle
léonard casimir a dîné à dîner chez
casimir bon nous mangerons c'est chou
farci c'est une surprise ils ne savent
pas seulement moi j'ai un petit ennui
c'est que j'ai j'ai mal tourné a
continué alors je n'aurai pas le temps
de préparer la farce
au fait savez vous ce que c'est qu'une
farce 1 tu le sais pas toi non plus
vous ne faites jamais de farce alors bon
ben voilà une farce c'est très simple
voile à ccc de la viande hachée menu
menu avec des herbes avec des épices et
comme ça et tout cela on le on le met
soi dans un poisson dans une volaille ou
wallon dans ce chou voilà où j'ai trouvé
je vais demander à julie de me cuisiner
une farce joli joli j'y allais pas là
tant pis je vais
laisser ça je vais téléphoner à casimir
l eau halo halo halo halo alors oui oui
allez olla léonard bonjour c'est ces
thèmes il campagne à l'appareil très
très bien merci très bien très bien
voilà léonard jeu je voudrais te
demander un service
est ce que toi ou casimir vous seriez
capable de faire une phase pour le dîner
de ce soir
oui oui parfait aux personnes non ça n'a
aucune importance toi ou kazimierz enfin
celui qui se faire là mais en face merci
il très bien alors ce soir l'arrêt c'est
pourquoi
je te dis que c'est moi qui sait faire
les meilleurs farce ah non monsieur
c'est moi oh quel prétentieux azimi
russe vantard
ça suffit comme ça je vais appeler
mademoiselle fut terre comment son
numéro
voilà allo mademoiselle futé oui c'est
casimir vous venez vite un et on arrive
moi nous sommes en train de nous
disputer et nous avons besoin de votre
arbitrage d'accord a tout de suite elle
arrive à
nous en étions nous
c'est à ton tour de m'insulter ouais
l'espace d'un vilain pas beau
pas mal pas mal mon vit-on tout a très
bien très bien à temps
rona minable
crâne sans poils
bien mais l'idée d'une rose mais enfin
ne vous disputez pas comme des
chiffonniers qu'est ce qui vous a évoqué
toujours de breuty c'est cet espace avec
cette espèce c'est ce gros diplo danton
a fait un pas tous les deux en même
temps léonard tuer la parole merci voilà
le facteur a demandé à celui de nous
deux qui fait les meilleurs face d'en
faire une pour ce soir pour le dîner ce
renard prétend que c'est lui qui sait
faire les meilleurs farce alors qu'il
est évident que c'est moi je l'étais
voilà ce que je vous propose vous allez
chacun paraît une farce et je vous dira
ensuite quel est le meilleur passeur
vous êtes d'accord d'accord d'accord ok
et en plus c'est mieux sera ravie
d'avoir deux sens au lieu dit alors tu à
faire c'est prête léonard ouais je suis
fin prêt mademoiselle futé j'espère que
les convives ne vont pas tarder à venir
regarder mes amis près de la porte il y
a une grosse pièce de monnaie je les
attacher avec un fil invisible celui qui
voudra l'apprendre se penchera pour la
ramasser et moi la up je tire un grand
coup et la pièce lui échappe c'est pas
triste
prestation léonard voilà pro x
vous aussi manoise inquiété j'allais
voir le roi de la farce en action
[Rires]
bonjour tout le monde ah y'a personne si
le premier
au passage il faut mieux être en avance
plutôt en retard c'est préférable
voilà
au tien d'une pièce de monnaie les
émirats dû l'oublier bon ben je vais la
ramasse et je la lui rendrait
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé la pièce
de monnaie à avancer tout seul
non mais je leur ai vu une pièce de
bonne équipe qui avance tout seul c'est
c'est pas vrai 2 et 3
chapman
match qui
s'est rendu compte de rien
j'entends la julie non j'ai pas lui en
parler parce qu'elles croient que je
suis complètement fou l'enjeu
[Rires]
c'était une farce ou
non le roi de la
frappe était très bonne je t'aimais 8
bat il faut attendre celle de casimir il
fera peut-être mieux que toi au banc
entre nous ce sera pas difficile de
nommer le lafarge de léonard et
véhicules j'ai fait semblant de marché
de laisser prendre au piège comme ça
pour lui faire plaisir
parce que en plus d'une traite de
menteur et bien puisque c'est comme ça
léonard je m'en vais
il est très vexé
et bien voilà julie s'aperçoit au bout
du chemin audi dont j'espère qu'elle
fera plus confiance et que françois
aubin évidemment là la farce que léonard
à pierre françois était du plus mauvais
goût dans les cra mienne c'est du gag
intelli enfin spir est là
comment mais mettez-vous ailleurs il
n'ya pas plus pour derrière la route
dans le buffet et le trophée du fair
alors dans la malle
aux ados sont mitigés quant aux
deux messieurs voilà je me
tiens encore personne
label soupière
est ce une soupe aux légumes
une soupe aux poissons
je n'ai pas peur je suis dit c'est une
force souris
mais ça ne ferait que mangera pas les
partis
mi
juin je lis pas les vexer à lourtier
aubin pourtant je trouve que t'as faim
tu es très réussi et casimir jeu des
nuits qui ont dit merci
bonsoir la compagnie je vois même jury
hier françois que j'ai rencontré furieux
oui je suis arrivé je sais combien je
leur ai rien dit là surprise alors dites
moi vous avez préparé la face aux
facteurs cette farce stupide c'était une
idée de vous
ils en ont fait une chacun
bon moral l'important c'est que le chou
farci soit bon
jeu les patients c'est si
la force n'est pas trop grasse et
contient beaucoup de bonnes herbes
hachées menu donc on va se régaler de
haut alors la face la farce casimir
enfin ces facteurs c'est que la farce
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de fatwa
[Musique]